what's going on um what you've got here
is a whole bunch of statements okay
credit cards are done from month to
month just like if you were earning
interest right you'd get a monthly
statement and you'd say okay this is how
much you've earned right
so you can see what's going on you start
with an opening balance so that's how
much you have spent on the credit card
in this case it looks like maybe the
person opened the account on the first
of march okay
now this date this opening date is very
important right the opening date here
the opening date is important
because once the account opens for the
month the clock starts ticking
okay the bank will give you some amount
of time to pay back however you much you
spend within this time period within
this month okay and it all starts from
the opening day so for example for this
particular credit card they're going to
give you
55 interest-free days which equates to
55 days
to pay
from this date when it's opened up okay
from the opening day
okay
so
anything that you buy within march or
pay for within march on this credit card
right you're going to have to pay off
within 55 days of the 1st of march okay
now in this case they've already worked
out for you 55 days from the 1st of
march you can see is the 24th of april
okay so this here
is plus 55 days that's how that's where
that number comes from okay so in some
senses the idea is that you start buying
things on the first of march you go all
the way through to the end of the month
and then when you get to march
30th okay you're like okay there's my um
there's all of my things for the month
and now i've kind of got a few weeks
just to tidy up and make sure i've
headed off okay
so you get to that time in april now
have a look at the things that have been
purchased so far you've got march 8th
they've bought some furniture
setting up home march 17 they've bought
some hardware okay now this 55 day
interest free period right it doesn't
apply to these individual items it
applies to the whole statement okay so
therefore you don't actually get 55 days
free on that piece of furniture
how many days would you get
if you get 55 days from the 1st of march
then how many days are there left by the
8th of march
it'll be minus minus 7 days right a week
has passed between here and here okay so
that would make it 48 days
to pay off this piece of furniture does
that make sense
and by the same logic uh i think off the
top of my head i think it's 39 days
to pay off this hardware okay so this 55
days doesn't reset for every single item
and that kind of makes sense right
because who is the person that you're
getting all this money from answer
the bank right and the bank started your
account here whereas these guys they're
like i don't know where the money comes
from i don't care as long as i get it
right so 55 days gets managed by the
bank
so here's the opening balance here's the
closing balance
which means that in the space of this
month at the end of march how much did
this person pay off of their debts
answer nothing yeah they've just left it
all sitting there and that's kind of
okay so far but
but
because there's money there
because there's a closing balance here
they're going to make you pay something
right they won't let you get away with
just sitting around and not paying
anything off they're going to charge and
i think it's right here
ten dollars or
three percent of the closing balance
whichever one is higher okay
so they calculate three percent of this
three percent of that and what it comes
down to is
and 52.41 cents okay so they're like
which one's higher 10
52
this one's higher so that's what they
charge you does that make sense
okay
now this is going to ruin all the things
i've written on the board and people got
those down yeah okay let me show you the
next one you don't have to write it but
let me show you what's happening
okay here we go
so what's happened
new month has started
new transactions in terms of things that
have been purchased right but right here
on the 24th of april
that's an important date on the 24th of
april they make a payment question why
did they pay on such a random day
because that was the due date okay now
hold on a second just as a matter of
fact it looks like they had that amount
of money ready to go okay why do you
think they didn't pay it off any earlier
why do you think they waited to the last
second to pay it off
this is the amount right
um up until april 23 right this well
actually for any time this amount of
money can be in one of two places okay
it's either in your bank account
or it's in theirs okay so if it's with
you right here's you
for every day this amount of money is in
your bank account what's it doing it's
not just sitting there it's earning
interest right so of course you want to
hold on to this money as long as
possible don't give it to these guys as
much as i'd like it right as soon as
it's in their hands they're entering the
interest and they can do stuff with it
okay so if they give you 55 days
wait for 55 days right don't give the
money back to them sooner um don't worry
they won't thank you for even if you
give it back to them earlier so they
wait to last moment they pay it off okay
and then they buy something else right
so the opening balance started from here
right
they paid that off
see
minimum payment due was this but they
decided not to do the minimum payment
they decided to pay off the lot okay
so here's what's left which is just
comprised of these two figures right so
how did they work out this figure here
where did it come from
good so it was the two choices they
calculated three percent of this which i
think is gonna be like six dollars okay
they're like well i can make more money
if i charge them ten dollars right so
there's always this minimum bar and
that's what they've chosen 25th of may
where did that come from
55 days plus april 1st
but on april 11th they bought something
else
yeah sure okay so what you've got to
consider this is why it's so good that
we have all of this here consider each
statement kind of as its own
self-contained thing okay so here's your
march bundle of money and how much is
owing on that okay when april begins
that march one kind of gets closed off
nothing gets added back to it because
i'm not in march anymore right so the
amount that was owing on that was 1 747
right
when they put this in this goes under
the april statement
okay and so therefore when they paid off
this it's like okay march is over and
now april's begun and all of these sums
go on to a new closing balance
so if they bought something
right so this april 11 thing right it
comes under april and the 55 days you
get free take you to the 25th of may
okay so each month is its own thing why
do you think they do that why do you
think they
divide it up like that that's more
manageable for us
yeah that's right it's kind of like look
people's minds get too confused if
they're like um look i've got all these
things and they're all just mixed
together okay also for the bank right i
want to make sure you pay me back right
so i can go and chase you and i can say
look this is the sum of money this is
the particular sum of money that i'm
after and it's due on this particular
day right otherwise it's very very hard
to organize the due dates because then
every single thing will have its own 55
days
really confusing okay yep
okay so let's suppose right um there's
one or two scenarios right so we hit
24th of april okay we hit 24th of april
now because there was a minimum payment
due right
you've got to pay this or you're in
breach of contract right and then
they'll start well they will forcibly
get this money out of you okay so
they'll get that one way or another
but if all you do is pay that minimum
amount right okay so
you've got one seven four seven minus
the minimum amount okay so what's left
uh let's see one six
uh nine
five six i'm just gonna say nine
something okay so now this this is still
sitting in uh
in my account as you owe me this
right and i gave you 55 days to pay you
haven't paid it so now i'm gonna start
charging you interest on it okay and
that's going to be a really really large
song 13
19 whatever depends on what kind of
credit card you've got okay
all right really good questions does
that make sense so far
let's have a look at some of the
questions rather than um
keep talking here all right so i'll zoom
out a bit more
i'll give you some time to think of this
right i will have to zoom out
unfortunately so you can see the data
that you need but let's just understand
the questions first
question 103 refer to the credit card
shown in the print statements on the
previous page that's what you just wrote
down okay
the minimum payment for this credit card
is this ten dollars or three percent
okay so they're just going to ask you to
try and work out well if these are the
closing balances suppose okay how much
are you gonna have to pay for each one
so you think about it what are you gonna
have to calculate
first you'll need to calculate what is
three percent of these closing
statements and then you need to make a
choice is it bigger than ten dollars or
not okay
for this credit card what would be the
due date for purchases made in now if
they give you these dates right so
here's a month right the first day is
june 1st
so to work out its payment date you
would add
55 days right and you'll get a date
to send the first
you are going to add 55 days and then
you get a date okay they say february
not a leap year why do they do that
to make sure that when you add the 55
you'll land on the right day within
march does that make sense